all right good morning
I'm shadi we're gonna be talking about
audio Steven showed a very short demo of
audio two nights ago we had two talks
that went over basics and and again
showed a little bit about audio but I
think that series of three talks we have
planned for today shows things that
either are easy one-liners doable and
fun and practical that can be done today
with Mathematica Anna logos beyond shows
the plan that we have basically are kind
of our to-do list or the or at least a
snippet to our to-do list for the next
year and years to come I would say the
introduction of audio in version 11 was
basically just a phase 0 has I call it
as it takes a lot of engineering work to
get at least that all your GUI that you
see that works seamlessly plays
streaming you know in core out of core
and all of those into the wolfram
mathematica and then really the meet is
coming a lot of processing is going to
be coming a lot of analysis is going to
be coming and some cool effects some of
them are easy we're going to be showing
them now but please give us feedback as
that to-do list is evolving as we speak
so I'll start by some fun things like
things effects are going to be mostly
cool if you already have a audio piece
that you want to add some kind of an
effect to it make it more fun or
actually make it more useful in sense of
removing the noise or highlighting some
specific frequency bands or add a reverb
to it so that it feels like you're
playing it and some bigger auditorium or
something like that these are all kinds
of effects that people typically like to
apply to their audio signal so let's
just get started with some effects that
are fairly easy to implement here I have
a drum signal the audio is not coming
out
I don't hear it okay close enough can
you make it from a little effective out
of that as well so what this tremolo
effect is is actually tries to modify
the amplitude of the audio signal as
you're playing it so giving it you know
it sounds louder you know that's loud
and so forth okay so basically this is a
very simple wave that I'm adding to the
amplitudes of the audio signal so as you
listen to it goes up again comes down
again and it's fairly easy I was
emphasizing on this before yesterday and
I want to emphasize that again with all
the capabilities that comes with
Mathematica creating the kind of wave
that you want to multiply to your signal
to get a higher frequency and going up
and down in loudness it's fairly easy
and all we had to do as far as frame
work stuff is to give capability for
simply multiplying your audio signal
with another signal that is being
generated with this piece of code which
is all your generation of a sine wave
with the frequency and then shifted so
it doesn't go below zero blah blah blah
so it's really it's it's really we're
really trying to show all the
capabilities of Mathematica that can
help us create these kinds of effects
and analyze all you that comes next in
the next talk another set of effects
that people typically like to create our
distortions and you know
moving the amplitude values up and down
taking them out of range and so forth so
if you look at the hyperbolic tangent
that's the plot and if you apply that to
an all your object that's how it's gonna
sound so where your arbitrary you can
just play with all the numeric functions
to see what makes this is kind of an art
you can't say what's correct what's
incorrect it's just what is fun so
similarly this is a cosine wave and just
apply to your audio you get a different
effect all of that and this is basically
some people's profession so and other
kinds of things that are very typical in
the audio world or if our delays a very
simple delay you basically have an audio
signal and you decade repeat it may be
added to the original signal maybe get
rid of the original signal some of these
very common ones mean we made them
actual audio functions in Mathematica so
that you can actually pass the
parameters that are very commonly useful
like the duration of the delay and a
feedback factor or the K factor how much
you want to mix the input audio with the
resulting audio and so forth so if you
listen to the rule 30 which has been in
Mathematica for a long time and then
added a lathe back to it
so it's kind of repeating but that point
four seconds of a delay time that has
been specified
and by the way useful to say that most
of these arguments can be specified
using the quantity specification that we
have in Mathematica so if you really
care if you have a very long audio you
want to specify the duration in minutes
hours and so forth you know these
quantities really come in handy and then
the next thing I'm showing it's kind of
a chorus effect which takes a bunch of
delays and then adds them off together
so basically what I have is a table of
audio delay of my original signal with
some random delay value and then I shift
the pitch a little bit again very
typical for chorus effect I'll talk
about pitch shift later and then compute
the mean of all of those all your
objects that were computed so so it just
feels a bit richer when you do this it's
it sounds like this is not the very
correct way accurate way of creating a
course effect but the point behind
course is that it feels like multiple
people are playing that same piece or
multiple people just just like so many
people singing the same piece rather
than just one person it just makes the
audio a bit richer reverberation as I
said earlier is a more sophisticated way
of echoing your signal from the
environment that you're in and typically
you get an impulse response of say you
know just a bang and then you get the
response of that bang from the walls and
the environment around it and then that
becomes what you convolve any other
signal whether to get the effect of that
same environment that same rule so since
I haven't played this yet right then
perfect timing this is just a male voice
and this is the reverb and some random
environment of our choice perfect timing
and then you can get an impulse response
of any environment we have again a
couple of them in example data like this
st. Mary Church right
perfect time and you see that the echo
is coming there all audio reverb is is
well there are various implementations
of audio reverb but basically how you
can look at it as convolving a signal
with the impulse response signal and
then just a couple of other cool effects
that we are creating here we are using
some some other signals not necessarily
impulse responses like the class
so basically multiple signals and then
convolving the signal with that so kind
of feels like you have multiple impulse
responses over time and yeah again this
is there there is nothing correct when
we are talking about effects it's just
how cool or how fun it is again this
this one that the church bill is
triggering the reverberation effect or
some water it might be nice if you have
the notebook just play these audio
themselves so that you get a better
sense kind of feels like the all you on
the rain okay so this is just one other
again kind of a random example using the
delays and so forth that show that
synthesis the simulation of a vibrating
string so what we're doing here is that
we get the frequency of the of the
vibrating string that we want to
simulate specify a larger feedback and
you start from a very small very short
noise and all we do is that we are
creating a delay as so many of them add
them together and it really sounds like
a vibrating signal and then you add a
couple of those different frequencies
together it sounds like like strumming a
chord basically on a guitar
and what we are doing to actually get
that strumming effect here just to show
us a little bit of the different details
we are patting at the beginning so that
it has the shift in time so that the
they are basically played one after each
other so time stretching and pitch
shifting again very common effects that
people use will get the same male voice
the point of time stretching you can
basically think about you you want to
stretch the duration or shrink the
duration and you can think about it a
very simple way is just to extract the
data we sample it and put it back but
then in that case you'll change the
pitch so proper time stretching is
trying to change the duration perfect
timing
without touching the pitch so trying to
preserve the pitch as much as possible
but change the duration so this one is
making it faster perfect timing
or again a very convenient to have the
choice of entering the some of these
arguments as quantity so you can say I
want the duration of the final output to
be four seconds frequency shifting and
pitch shifting what frequency shifting
is doing is that it tries to shift not
troy's it actually what it does it
computes a short the short time a short
time okay
okay it actually tries to compute all
the frequencies and shift them by a by a
constant value so as this picture is
trying to show if the signal has two
fundamental frequencies it moves them to
f1 plus frequency and f2 plus frequency
right then thanks to timing and then one
thing that we want to do more of what we
haven't managed to put it in every
single audio function that was
introduced in version 11 are these kinds
of time varying arguments so here I said
shift the frequency of my audio by 200
Hertz shifted up by 200 Hertz but I can
have this argument be time varying so
for every time of my audio I do a
different shift
perfect timing so you can see that it
goes up it goes down and then it goes up
then it goes down and right then but I
think timing probably just to repeat I
don't know why I put that in there so
pitch shift on mic frequency shift
multiplies the pitch the frequencies
that were detected by a specific factor
so again the point right
perfect timing this is to get different
pitch kind of mimic different person's
voice perfect timing
so here we are moving it by two semi
tones up or down compression and
expansion we don't have specific audio
functions for them but not that they're
necessarily difficult what they mean is
that they're trying to make the whole
the overall or you know if I can just
show that platform and they're basically
trying to reduce and the dynamic range
of the audio or increase it so what they
do in the case of compression as you see
in that thought they're trying to
attenuate the pieces of the audio that
are loud and so that they basically it
becomes more of a equally distributed
based on the RMS amplitude or the
loudness that we are computing so what
I'm doing here is that I'm creating a
time series of I created the amplitudes
up there and then i'm tresh holding
based on a specific threshold which was
that threshold up there in the plot and
then smoothing it a little bit then
whenever I have values amplitude values
smaller than the given threshold I would
like to keep it as it is when I vary its
higher than the threshold I want to
bring it down and then I normalize it so
that it's still at the same almost the
same there were a lot of people my age
sorry let me play the original there are
a lot of people my age that need the
pass in this area so as you see there
are some place some some intervals of
this audio signal that is quieter than
the rest of us in in this
and if I plotted you see that what has
happened these these sections that are
fairly damp are becoming closer in
amplitude value to the rest of it since
we are normalizing it seems like we are
basically expanding those silent pieces
but what we're doing is we are damping
the louder pieces and then normalizing
so that it comes back as you see there
is no and there is that the dynamic
range of the audio overall during that
duration of the signal is more uniform
so expansion is basically kind of the
inverse of that it's trying to find
those quiet sections and diminish them
make them a lot of people move even
quieter and as you see here these pieces
in the original signal we had some noise
that they are becoming quieter so that
kind of reduces the noise that is an
epimer a lot of people my age that made
in this area it's difficult to compare
probably would be better if you do it
locally anyways creating an equalizer we
have a complete suite of signal
processing capabilities in Mathematica
one thing that is new are in the pool of
functions as a by quadratic filter model
which is basically giving us very bits
it's actually very common for creating
these kinds of effects if you look at
the diagrams of how these effects are
being created how the transfer function
models are being created they're very
often just a series and connections of
some biquadratic filter models so we
have low shelf ice shelf peaking and so
forth here I'm creating those and then
connecting them serially together and
then here is a small GUI that shows for
this periodic random noise it basically
almost has all the frequencies we are
trying to show how the equalizer can
change some pieces of the frequencies
you basically would like to put favor
for some of the frequencies in the
signal and then diminish the rest of
them so that's that and then if I change
say the gain of the peaking frequency
you said maybe enlarge that you
basically get a different response
that's basically the frequency response
of the modified signal and obviously it
was audible that the signal is different
just just to have a bit more fun with
that this was the drums that I played at
the beginning let's change a few of them
let's change a bit more harder to hear
but any of you that have probably worked
in the field have had equalizers and now
these are typically these panels that
you can shift the knobs up and down and
so forth more effects by modifying the
short time Fourier transform so here I
have a fairly noisy audio signal return
and here's a spectrogram some so many
effects are a lot easier and in fact a
lot of the ones that I showed are being
applied to that short time Fourier
transform of audio signals this function
that is in your builds in the eleven
eleven oh one eleven builds actually but
we didn't manage to polish it enough to
be released as a function is giving you
a function that gets applied to every
single value this is this is showing the
magnitude of the short time Fourier
transform but you in fact if you call
the spectrogram array you get a bunch of
complex numbers and this function gets
applied to every single complex function
of that spectrogram array and then we
compute the inverse of that to get the
modified well this one is using a white
noise and tries to okay so one thing
again these are no promises this
function if gets released is gonna have
the same structure but the plan is that
this function that this arbitrary
function that can be specified gets two
arguments one of them is the value that
you get back for every single response
and the short time Fourier transform and
the other one could be the time and so
so here we are just showing a simple
example of using
and as you see I started from just five
seconds of a white noise but based on
the time that I'm specifying and I don't
recall what was the third argument
frequency yes time and frequency so we
get the value time and frequency so
there are there are just a ton of things
that can happen with these kinds of
functions more of it it's going to be
coming in the next version and then this
is basically the last slide before we
move on to more serious stuff we were
thinking we're looking at this short
time for is for a short time Fourier
transform of an audio signal and there
are some community posts and blogs and
marketing examples about converting an
image to an audio or an audio to an
image and blah blah blah and then I
thought we have all of these image
processing capabilities of course why
wouldn't I think about it and then what
what we decided to do is to come up with
we have an image transformation function
that gets an arbitrary function moves
every XY coordinate of the image to a
new X prime Y prime coordinate and in
the image so all we're doing here is
that we are computing the spectrogram
and I wish we had matrix transform as
well as the image transform maybe we
should have it but we're sticking with
real and imaginary part of this
spectrogram array into an image and
actually calling image transformation on
it then do they inverse to get a new
audio object so let me run all all of
this notebook or slide because some of
them take long and then I can basically
go through them one at a time
so so this that's basically gradient
image is just showing what kind of a
transformation we are applying to every
one of these spectrogram arrays so this
first one is basically taking every XY
coordinate and push it to an X Y to the
power of one point two and this is the
kind of a transformation you see that's
the spectrogram and which audio I'm
using the noisy talk the one that the
lady was speaking so let me actually
play that once again now I can't
okay no clue you remember because the
other cells that I run are already
evaluating again
sorry no science behind any of these
these are just fun things we came up
with yesterday
this one is reversing the XY coordinate
as you see so basically puts the time
domain over frequency and kind of sounds
like a creek oh yeah it's kind of empty
at the beginning because there are not
so many responses on the top of the
frequency space this one is mosaic image
so basically gets every chunk every like
rectangle computes the mean and then
replaces all of the pixel values with
that so did the same thing to the what
the lady was saying this is a kind of a
rain effect feels like XY z-- are coming
down or in the Y direction they're
coming down again same effect applied to
the spectra the fisheye effect failed
but actually I don't find mm-hmm what is
failing here let's see we got an audio
object back I don't think it was worth
maybe I changed something last minute
okay well let me run them again they
were working before all right
I still have practically four minutes I
can still a bit from Carla as well who's
coming next but this is basically the
last talk and as I said this this we
make made these three talks in a row and
this was the sweet easy one Carla is
going to show us the meat of the
analysis and synthesis which which has a
lot of use you know in various domains
of research and development and in fact
some digital composers made likes or
moving towards doing these kind of
program programmatic synthesis and Carla
himself is a musician or I can say
so anyways very exciting talks really
would like to encourage you to don't be
for another hour thank you
[Applause]